[Musica]
[Applauso]
pomeriggio a tutti gli do fa due cose
una mi dicono di stare fermo e l'alta di
guardare in alto due cose che per me
sono complicate
avevo chiesto a mia moglie se poteva
portare un tappeto con diametro di 8
metri ma effettivamente non è possibile
ringrazio organizzatori per l'invito
devo dire che c'è un po pensato prima di
rispondere e di accettarlo
in realtà quello che avete ascoltato
della presentazione prevete un po troppo
realtà io faccio l'imprenditore però
quando ho risposto quando ho accettato
l'invito
mi sono chiesto quale potesse essere la
declinazione la mia declinazione del
termine mind penn di sicura di avere
cura di e francamente un po analizzando
a pensandoci ho visto che calzava
secondo me è abbastanza bene con quello
che era la mia vita quello che la mia
professione che la migliore la più bella
professione del mondo quella di fare
l'imprenditore
mi chiamo luca e voglio fare
l'imprenditore e forse anche il
camionista
questa è una risposta che diedi a una
insegnante in cui tele mentale che mi
chiese che chiedevano i giovani nei
bimbi cosa volessimo fare della nostra
vita
in realtà non avevo ben chiaro corsa
volessimo dovesse dire fare
l'imprenditore però mi piaceva l'idea di
creare di fare in realtà poi dopo molti
anni ho scoperto che in realtà le due
cose sono realizzate fare l'imprenditore
e forse fare i kilometri che fa un
camionista perché effettivamente
viaggiamo molto
mio padre era un medico ci ha cresciuti
con l'idea del prendersi cura delle cose
del paese sicuro soprattutto del
prossimo ma soprattutto di amare quello
che facciamo
io sono cresciuto
in una famiglia serena mio padre mia
sorella mia madre ci hanno innescato il
meccanismo del fare a prescindere lì è
la testimonianza di oggi che volevo in
qualche modo dare
parte da questo presupposto fare a
prescindere lì la mia diciamo a
vocazione di fare impresa ripeto nasce
molti anni fa ho avuto anche la fortuna
non so se la fortuna se fosse un caso
avete qualcosa anche voluto di avere
opportunità di esprimere di esprimermi i
diversi ambiti
io sono un imprenditore prestato alla
manifattura perché prima mi sono
occupato nasco nel mondo della
comunicazione
mi occupo di digitale la mia carriera
professionale una carriera che ha
probabilmente come minimo comune
denominatore il concetto di fare a
prescindere di da nasco quindi come uomo
di marketing le mie prime attività sono
legate al mondo del digitale al mondo
della comunicazione e probabilmente da
lì che nasce anche ha forse un po la mia
volontà di capire meglio cosa vuol dire
fare impresa
la mia vita si evolve ripeto punto fermo
la famiglia e da quella da quale son
partito è quella che poi ritorna sempre
nel cammino nel progetto
diciamo di vita
mi ricordo la mia prima esperienza fu
quella di dire di andare da mio padre e
raccontarle di un'idea avevo ventisei
ventisette anni avevo in qualche modo
studiato per in parte aveva interrotto
gli studi papà voglio aprire un'agenzia
di comunicazione
mio padre era medico non capì però si
fidò ecco da questa fiducia poi è
partito tutto
il secondo capitolo della mia vita che è
quello del quale vi racconterò oggi è
quello che è presente ha lasciato che
sta lasciando il segno più forte su di
me hai capito legato alle mani
direte le mani 91 che si occupa di
comunicazione si occupa di marketing ma
le mani e infatti io le mani fino a
cinque anni fa non avevo mai considerate
nel mio modo di vedere di ter prendere e
l'avvenuta nelle barche e stato un caso
io sono arrivato nelle marche sono
veneto che lo si senta quattro anni fa
proprio abbagliato in qualche modo
stregato dalle mani
ebbi l'occasione di vedere di incontrare
di vedere un'azienda manifatturiera che
oggi la mia azienda ebbe l'occasione di
vedere la passione di queste signore di
queste donne che lavoravano con le mani
che facevano che creavano io che in vita
mia non avevo mai usato le mani resta
abbagliato ripeto non so usare neanche
oggi non è che averlo visto mi ha
permesso di impararlo però 3 cambiò la
traiettoria della mia carriera
professionale ed al territorio
mi sa che ria professionale fu cambiata
anche dal territorio quindi le mani il
legame col territorio
oggi faccio l'imprenditore a tolentino
la mia è una realtà manifatturiera che
ha nell uso delle mani collegato
ovviamente la testa il suo principale
crime la sua principale forma di
esprimersi
il territorio è fondamentale ripeto
veneto marche 2 congiunzioni molto
simili per quello poi dio parlo a voi
credo di sapere cosa provate perché un
po ci vivo qua ma perché arriva da un
territorio molto simile attaccamento ai
valori attaccamento lavoro forte
vocazione all'apprendimento e anche se
vogliamo un territorio abbastanza
giovane e anche la chiave dei giovani è
importante
so che oggi la platea è mista
però vuole dire un messaggio prigione e
forse qualcosa di più
quindi manifattura l'uso delle mani
vengo abbagliato da questa da questa
opportunità
entro in questo mondo e resto
completamente stupito da questa capacità
di creare la mia azienda che produce
articoli di altissima gamma
ma al di là da quello che facciamo dalla
passione di queste persone passione e
territorio però mi accorgo che forse c'è
un corto circuito ma come abbagliato
questa capacità di fare però c'è un
problema che nel nostro settore nei
settori manifatturieri nel mondo della
fattura che è la spina dorsale sistema
italiano non c'è più gente che vuole
entrare mi trovo quindi a dover
comprendere che se l'azienda se il mondo
nel quale vivono non ha un futuro
probabilmente il territorio dal quale
arrivò il territorio al quale arrivo non
ha un futuro
nasce quindi l'esigenza di creare un
trait d'union tra quello che faccio
quello che le signore quelle che le mie
maestranze fanno e i nuovi mondi e da lì
nasce un po l'esigenza anche di
attrezzarmi per rendere attrattiva per
le nuove generazioni
la fabbrica io sono cresciuto ripeto in
aziende una famiglia con la forte
vocazione ma ristic a parlare di
fabbrica poteva sembrare forse anche un
po deviante in realtà la fabbrica dei
valori straordinari e intrinseche i
nuovi sapere da qui mi resi conto di
questa corte un circuito e della
necessità data di paul vi di dare un
futuro futuro al territorio futuro a me
stesso perché ripeto la traiettoria
della mia vita professionale è cambiata
arrivando qui vi darò un futuro
all'attività all'attività oro ma
soprattutto di cercare di inserire ed
insegnare di permettere alla generazione
di entrare in questi nuovi mondi
nasce un progetto di formazione
nasce il progetto legato ai giovani i
vecchi tra virgolette che insegnano i
giovani i giovani che vogliono imparare
dei vecchi ma all'interno di una
fabbrica cosa che potrebbe sembrare
strano nasce l'esigenza di raccontarsi
la mia capacità di essere un discreto
story teller aiuta aiuta i giovani si
appassionano prato con formazioni
diverse
perché oggi in azienda da noi in
fabbrica da noi abbiamo persone che
arrivano dalle arti mestieri perciò
cavalleresco professionale laureati e
via dicendo
il minimo comune natore eri concetto del
fare facendo ci viene in mente di
coniare questa frase il valore che
troviamo nel concetto di fare facendo è
il valore che mi ha sostanzialmente
guidato per tutta la vita nel senso che
è fondamentale l'azione è quello che
oggi mi sento di dare come spunto di
riflessione a tutti voi in tutti gli
anni della mia carriera
per certi versi poliedrica ma comunque
scandita dai venti
il minore conventuale stato se è quello
dell'azione l'azione e la volontà di
fare cose di farle bene e di lavorare
sulla qualità di quello che si fa eco il
fare facendo è esattamente quello che
serve è quello che serviva a noi per
dare un messaggio soprattutto alle nuove
generazioni non aspettare ma agire oggi
la mia esperienza è piena di tutto
questo l'azienda la realtà nella quale
vivo che l'alterata del territorio gode
di quelli che sono i valori del
territorio non vi nego
siamo passati anche noi purtroppo per
l'evento del 2016
non vi nego che non è stato il che è
stato difficile però devo anche dire che
quel passaggio che per molti è stato una
frattura indelebile per noi stato
momento è un motivo di grande rinascita
rinascita o comunque di grande
evoluzione perché nasce vuol dire che
fosse
non ci sei più però di evoluzione
l'evoluzione di di poter continuare e
andare avanti
quindi fondamentalmente il concetto sul
quale abbiamo lavorato e che mi sento di
condividere con voi che nell'azione
l'attesa non serve oggi il nostro
territorio il territorio marchigiano ha
bisogno di azione e ha bisogno
dell'azione dei giovani esiste
probabilmente un momento di
consapevolezza la consapevolezza che
fondamentalmente il valore che c'è in
tutto quello che stiamo facendo è un
valore molto molto alto
l'altro giorno peraltro vi racconto un
piccolo particolare
io vivo molto vivo molto l'azienda mi
piace stare con i giovani mi piace stare
con le maestranze che hanno esperienza e
ato giorno mi si avvicina un giorno dei
neoformati neurone assunti mi dice
guardi bortolami man si dice luca io
devo io devo ringraziarla perché perché
a un certo punto ho creduto è un ragazzo
diventi una ragazza di 25 26 anni ho
creduto che mio percorso professionale
non potesse mai partire perché non aveva
in mano gli strumenti oppure pensavo di
non averli in realtà mai avrei pensato
che in fabbrica avrei trovato gli
strumenti per realizzarli imparare una
professione imparare un mestiere essere
nelle condizioni anche probabilmente di
se succederà sarà l'opportunità anche di
tramandarlo ecco per me questo è stato
un motivo di grande soddisfazione di
grande orgoglio e anche probabilmente il
motivo per cui chi fa impresa
a un certo punto si rende conto di
essersi preso cura di non ho la
ambizione di dire mise un peso di cura
delle persone ma probabilmente forse un
po di consapevolezza di essermi preso
cura di qualcosa che è di più
nel raccontare ma è appunto il saper
fare e questa consapevolezza è secondo
me è determinante e importante quindi un
messaggio fondamentale per i giovani
un altro aspetto sul quale credo sia
importante lavorare è legato al fatto
che ho comunque realizzare che da dove
arriviamo
è importante e fondamentale cioè la
nostra estrazione è determinante il
territorio il le gambe cordone
ombelicale è il fattore di valore
aggiunto e non dimenticatelo mai
si chiama cultura e di questo il nostro
territorio le marche in particolar modo
sono pregne cultura cultura che non è
necessariamente cultura perché siamo
all'interno di un teatro la cultura di
dove viviamo il concetto del bello il
concetto di aver fatto
guardate viaggio il mondo ceca mi è
capitato diverse volte di guardare con
gli occhi da italiano quello che alti
fanno all'estero e credetemi i nostri
occhi sono diversi sono diversi perché
hanno catturato negli anni della nostra
storia elementi diversi che sono il
paesaggio che sono il territorio quali
viviamo e che sono probabilmente il bel
vivere
ecco questi non sono cose da da
trascurare
e tutti assolutamente civile e in questo
senso il territorio credo sia sia molto
molto fondante molto forte nella
responsabilità di prendersi cura
poi c'è l'aspetto probabilmente anche
più interessante che è quello secondo me
di rendere qualcosa che durerà anche un
po dopo di te ce di tramandare di
trasmettere e questo ringrazio
nell'attività nel fare impresa nella mia
vocazione a fare imprenditore è sempre è
sempre stato e sempre presente oggi che
sono forse l'età di consapevolezza sono
ancora giovane
ma forse un po di esperienza passata e
che o perché il figlio di bimbe piccole
una splendida moglie o quindi la
consapevolezza dei valori
mi rendo ancora più conto di quanto
veramente sia importante lavorare su
questo quindi se posso darvi un
messaggio perché ci vivo quotidianamente
vivo qui
ci sono degli aspetti che reputo
straordinari ci sono altri sui quali si
può lavorare e non attendere non
aspettare non aspettare altri lavorate
lavorate sulle vostre vocazioni lavorate
sull'azione è meglio se vogliamo
sbagliare per eccesso di azione che non
attendere perché si e insicuri oggi
nell'era dei social dove molto facile
avere un'idea prendere una posizione è
una posizione statica il social o
comunque la parte digitale nella quale
viviamo ci permette di esprimere di
farci un'idea ma molto spesso ci limita
nell'azione perché si ritiene che il
mondo sia tutto lì no credo che l'azione
sia determinante lo ripeto tutti i
giorni in azienda
lo ripeto sempre a me stesso il concetto
di continuare fare cose per me è
importante la il secondo aspetto è forse
l'ultimo è quello di lavorare sulle
proprie capacità
ognuno di noi ha evidentemente una
marcia in più in qualcosa nella mia
piccola esperienza il mio comune
denominatore è stato sempre quello di
lavorare sulla mia capacità di
convincere una propensione a raccontare
quindi professione commerciale ma su
quella ho fondato sostanzialmente il mio
modo di essere
ecco ognuno ognuno di voi ognuno di voi
ognuno di voi sa qualcosa di particolare
lavorare su quello c'è chi dice ma
lavoriamo sulle proprie debolezze
no non ha senso lavoriamo se abbiamo una
forza costruiamo intorno a questa la
determinazione di fare e credo che ci
siano buone opportunità per riuscire io
volevo ringraziarvi sicuramente
dell'opportunità
arrivederci un ebook lupo a tutti grazie
[Applauso]